always wanted to perform when I grew up
watching you both of you guys and this
is pretty surreal I mean I practice how
to do the the late night the late night
host thing you did yeah yeah yeah I can
I can demonstrate I've studied a lot
you've studied how to be and you yet to
be the host order yeah because it's a
lotta it's a lot you know what the day
it's a lot kind of tapping I just got
rid of it yes yes I got rid of the desk
because I was realized for 25 years no
my it was all banged up and my wedding
ring gouged it out and I realized I
gotta get rid of it so yeah assaulting
my crotch all the time oh my god I don't
know why you did it
I used to see how you looked in denim no
I just was tied we wanted a change I
wouldn't change so I thought we'll take
that away yeah but you've got the moves
down well Bart can I borrow yeah yes
here yeah I think you want well it's a
lot alike so well first of all it's
always tapping it's playing playing with
this yeah yeah and then you're always
shown you're always showing like the DVD
perhaps we have Ice Road Truckers we
have Ice Road Truckers yeah and I'll
take all these so this is great so I
guess we'll start with that wow that was
great good job with the band will banter
later
guys I got a heck of a show from the
in the 2002 film family man Nicolas Cage
is not here I would have a great time
and bestie that steals here we love that
steal don't sure do not to mention Ice
Road Truckers all the truckers all the
truckers are here tonight and the trucks
we are struck the trucks are parked out
front I cannot wait and Bastille will be
performing a scene from the family man
I just that just made me miss the desk
we've all been doing this for like two
months and already I was looking it was
like oh I want to be doing that
[Laughter]
catch-22 premieres May 17th on Hulu so
check that out and that was Letterman he
would throw that stuff around
hey Jon rudnitsky
[Applause]